right here in the lobby of Ramsay
Solutions Alex and Selenia are with us
hey guys how are you
welcome welcome where're you guys from
we're from st. Louis Missouri very cool
well welcome to Nashville we're honored
to have you with us so you're here to do
a debt-free scream yes and how much have
you paid off we paid off $82,000 Dave
Wow and how long did that take felt like
forever but it was 33 months 33 months
that's close to forever and your range
of income during that time we started at
$100,000 a year and are now at a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars a year great
very cool so how'd you get a raise have
you heard the economy was bad yeah I go
to work
gotta go to work there it is very good
what do y'all do for a living I'm a
legal assistant man and now I'm an
aerospace engineer ah of course you are
okay we have a rocket scientist on site
yes I love it good good job guys it's
very fun so what kind of debt was the
$82,000 Dave that was our mortgage you
paid off your house yes you too we're 26
so what's the house worth it's about a
hundred and ten thousand dollars nothing
fancy but it's ours it's paid for by
gosh I'm like we're not talking this
down it's paid for way to go you two
very very cool
man so what in the world inspire you at
26 years old I have a paid-for house and
this happened 33 months ago so you start
working on they said like 23 yeah my
sister actually introduced us to your
plan and we had just gotten the condo
and I shared a story with Alex when I
was 8 years old my mom paid off her
house and that story stayed in my heart
forever so I thought hey I want a
paid-for a house - yeah Wow so Alex how
did what was your reaction when you
that you did you not say like other
people they will show what everybody's
got a mortgage I just thought that was
amazing and you know over the years of
our mayor's have gotten closer to
Salinas mom and I've seen you know how
it god is blessed her and I know that
just paying out that mortgage that many
years ago just helped set her up so much
for now you know years later and you
know we're gonna we can follow in her
footsteps so what's her first name my
mom isn't Gloria Gloria so I'm guessing
Gloria is one of those people that's
just wise yeah definitely just the
wisdom and that that witness to you knew
it okay this is what why it's a wise
person and this wise person paid off her
house and it left a mark on her daughter
so I'm in that's what you were seeing I
guess Alex yeah yes now very cool
that's very cool I can just kind of see
your face right now wow that's neat that
is very very neat you know I've I don't
know if I've ever heard the story told
this way I've often told people when
they bring their little kids in here to
do their debt-free screaming that little
eight-year-old kid is standing here that
you changed their family tree but that's
what your mom did she left a mark on you
when she paid that house off so do you
worry what do you remember about that
that's interesting
I remember rice and beans and potatoes
for two years and I remember being told
that I was gonna get it one day
okay all right oh that you get the house
one day that I was going to understand
why she was do oh yeah okay I thought
you might get the house okay yeah you
will someday probably but oh my gosh Wow
okay you may not understand now but
you'll understand later yeah
but then there was something that did
they celebrate or what was that how did
you remember that being eight years old
to being the specific time there's paid
off honestly I think that a lot of
things change around the house I
remember my mom being a lot more relaxed
and at ease and just that kind of peace
mm-hmm and that's stuck with an
eight-year-old yes I love this because
when I tell people they're changing
their family trees this illustrates it
for these parents out there that are
listening that are on your mom's side of
the equation you know and they're
looking at that eight-year-old in the
face that's you yeah that's that kid
grown up now wow that's such a legacy
that is so
powerful I love it I love it what a
quite a great testimony to her so what
did you all do to get out of debt in 33
months $82,000 is impressive in 33
months yeah Alex and I delivered pizzas
nice engineer bringing me my pizza yes
yes it's actually really funny we have a
little nephew who is thinking about
engineering and when he was ill we were
delivering pizzas he says I'm not sure
if I want to do engineering anymore you
have to deliver pizzas that's fun so you
left a mark on him I'm not sure it's a
good one but that's good so you worked
extra how much did you make delivering
pizzas in a month average both of you
did it but he was delivering our I know
in our neighborhood so I would see him
yeah it was a few hundred Dave I I was
also going to grad school part-time so I
pretty much at nights and weekends
okay just a few hundred but it did help
a little bit and not only that but just
being strategic I mean one of the
biggest sacrifices Dave is Selenia walks
to work every day
whoa and that was huge for us it still
is you to rest how far oh it's about a
mile oh just a mile yeah okay it's okay
st. Louis where it's warm in the winter
yeah wow you guys are impressive you are
impressive this is a I mean Gloria's got
to be hip proud yeah very cool
this is very neat very good what was the
hardest part of the three of the 33
months it was probably knowing that we
could be spending so much more and not
doing so we have very basic phones we
got made fun of so much we still have
those basic phone no cable and I don't
think we're going to get cable but well
you make $120,000 a year you don't even
have a house payment
I mean if you want a little cable or a
little better phone you're ready now you
have lived like no one else now you can
live and give like no one else
well I'm impressed you guys are very
you're heroes you're absolutely amazing
26 years old what paid for houses and
you could have been out there spending
like a crazy yuppie all over the place I
mean y'all could have been because you
made that you make the normal money or a
little better than normal money and man
you could have killed it you could have
gone into a real disaster instead you
turned it the other way yes and you're
gonna be so wealthy it's gonna be
amazing it's amazing because you're in
control and you're obviously in
communication with each other about this
just very well done all right we're
gonna give you a signed copy of Chris
Hogan's retire inspired book number one
bestseller thank you and that's the next
chapter is to continue to build wealth
and give and you're gonna be wealthy and
I'm gonna come out at the commercial
break and sign a legacy journey book for
Gloria because she has left a legacy I
mean this is pretty incredible
I like her and I've never even met her
that is very very cool stuff
very neat all right it's Alex and
Selenia st. louis missouri $82,000 paid
off house and everything making did that
over 33 months making 100 to 120 count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
that's how it's done right there just
knocked it out very very very well done
well there it is there's the proof the
proof is in the pudding right and an 8
year old little girl went and paid off
her house when she's 26 years old making
a hundred and twenty thousand living in
a hundred and twenty thousand dollar
house one hundred ten thousand dollar
house why cuz she remembered when she
was eight how the house how the air in
the household change the peace there was
something relaxed do you hear that
what happens when you do this stuff
instead of living strapped to the wall
stupid cars you can't afford stupid
vacations you can't afford making stupid
decisions over and over and over again
and can't figure out why your kids are
freaked out well there it is lady went
and changed her family tree and now
we're seeing it here twenty years later
in a paid-for house with her daughter
man I love that story this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income earner five
hundred thousand offering economy
you